جريمه مروعه هزت السودان ضحيتها ابنه
مسؤول مرتبطه بتفكيك النظام السابق فما
القصه
ثلاثه مجهولين قطعوا الطريقه على طفله
تبلغ من العمر 15 عاما واقتادوها عنوه تحت
التهديد تناوب الاعتداء عليها وطلبوا منها
تبليغ رساله لوالدها بانهم قادرون على
الوصول اليه
اسره الضحيه قدمت بلاغا بالواقعه وطالب
الوالد الشرطه بالقيام بدورها
يعني تقوم بدوره مش تجاه ترتيب فقط ااا
يعني تقوم بالدور الوقائي تجاه ترتيب
من كل ابنائه الشعب السوداني
[موسيقى]
في السودان الشرطه
بيان لمدير عام الشرطه وكبار قادتها في
ولايه الخرطوم اكد اسناد التحقيقات الى
فريق جنائي المختص بالبحث والتحري فيما
تمت الاستعانه بالاطقم الفنيه المختصه في
المعامل الجنائيه وبالكلاب البوليسيه كما
استخدمت التقنيات الحديثه لفك طلاسم
الجريمه بهدف تسريع الوصول الى الجناب
الجريمه اخذت اصداء كبيره بسبب بعدها
السياسي وفي ظل الجدل المستمر الذي يدور
حول عملي لجنه تفكيك النظام السابق والتي
تطالب ايضا عمليات الفساد